.
AND AMERICA'S UNDOING, THAT'S
"THE ANGLE."
JOINING ME NOW, INDEPENDENT
JOURNALIST GLENN GREENWALD, I
WAS WATCHING THIS ANNOUNCEMENT
UNFOLD TODAY.
I COULD NOT BUT HELP BUT NOTICE
KAMALA HARRIS, IT SOUNDS LIKE
THE OLD DHS INFORMATION BOARD
BUT NOW IT'S RUN OUT OF THE
WHITE HOUSE.
WHAT ARE YOUR THOUGHTS TONIGHT?
>> IT'S BIZARRE, ON THE ONE HAND
YOU CAN MARKET AND IS THE
TRIVIALITY AS IT IS, SUPPOSED TO
BE INTEGRATED INTO FOREIGN
POLICY TO GET HER BONA FIDES.
GOING TO SOLVE THE ROOT CAUSE
PROBLEMS IN CENTRAL AMERICA AND
STEM THE TIDE OF IMMIGRATION AND
ALL OF A SUDDEN SHE'S LIKE A
GLORIFIED CONTENT MODIFIER FOR
TWITTER TO PROTECT
"WASHINGTON POST" REPORTERS.
ON THE OTHER HAND, IT'S MORE
MENACING THAN THAT AND I THINK
IT'S PART OF THE VERY SUSTAINED
AND SYSTEMIC ATTEMPT ON THE PART
OF THE U.S. GOVERNMENT AND THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY TO CREATE
REGIMES OF CENSORSHIP AND
INFORMATION CONTROL OVER THE
INTERNET THE PLACE THAT WE NOW
USE MOST OF ALL TO GET OUR
INFORMATION AND OUR GLOBE
INFORMATION.
TO CENSOR IT FOR THEIR OWN
INTERESTS, HATE SPEECH,
DISINFORMATION.
THE FACT THEY HAVE THE ENTIRE
U.S. SECURITY STATE ASSEMBLED
MAKES IT CLEAR AT SOMETHING MORE
THAN JUST KIND OF A JOKE OR
ADJUSTER.
>> Laura: THAT WAS A SIGN, TO
HAVE THE PRESIDENT THERE,
MERRICK GARLAND, ALL THESE OTHER
AGENCY HEADS INCLUDING THE
SURGEON GENERAL.
WHO POPPED UP AT TODAY'S PRESS
CONFERENCE AS WELL.
WATCH.
>> IT COULD NO LONGER BE
ACCEPTABLE FOR A TECHNOLOGY
COMPANY TO PUT OUT A PRODUCT AND
WALK AWAY FROM THE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR HOW IT
IMPACTS USERS AND COMMUNITIES.
IF IT CAN NO LONGER BE OKAY FOR
SOCIAL MEDIA PLATFORMS TO BE
FERTILE GROUNDS FOR HATRED.
ACCOUNTABILITY MATTERS.
>> Laura: GLENN, WHERE IS THE
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHO PUSH THE LOCK
DOWNS ON KIDS THAT WENT ON IN
SOME CASES FOR ALMOST TWO YEARS?
SUICIDE, DRUG ABUSE, DESPAIR.
THAT WAS CALLED DISINFORMATION A
COUPLE OF YEARS AGO AND NOW IT'S
CALLED TRUTH.
WHO GETS TO DECIDE ALL OF THAT?
>> THIS IS THE CRITICAL PART
WHERE LISTENING TO THAT, IF
THAT'S INCREDIBLY MENACING AND
INSIDIOUS COME AT THE HEAD
ATTORNEY GENERAL ESSENTIALLY
SAYING, DIRECTING PRIVATE
COMPANIES, TWITTER, FACEBOOK,
GOOGLE, TELLING THEM YOU'RE NOT
ALLOWED TO AIR THIS KIND OF
INFORMATION THAT WE REGARD AS
HATEFUL OR WE REGARD -- THAT'S
NOT THE GOVERNMENT'S ROLE.
TO BE IN ARBITRATING OUR
POLITICAL DEBATES BY INSTRUCTING
PRIVATE COMPANIES ON WHAT THEY
CAN AND CANNOT DO.
THIS HAS BEEN THE MOST MISSED
UNDERSTOOD AND MOST OVERLOOKED
COMPONENT OF THE BIG TECH
CENSORSHIP WHICH IS DEMOCRATS
ALWAYS SAY IF YOU COMPLAIN ABOUT
CENSORSHIP, THESE ARE PRIVATE
COMPANIES AND THEY CAN DO WHAT
THEY WANT.
DEMOCRATS NEVER THOUGHT ABOUT
PRIVATE ENTERPRISE THAT WAY.
BUT THE REALITY IS THE WHOLE
TIME DEMOCRATS HAVE BEEN
THREATENING BIG TECH AND THE WAY
YOU HURRY TO COMMIT IF YOU DO
NOT CENSOR IN ACCORDANCE WITH
WHAT WE WANT, WE ARE GOING TO
IMPOSE REGULATORY AND LEGAL
REPRISALS ON YOU.
THIS IS COMING FROM THE
GOVERNMENT AND NOT EMANATING
FROM BIG TECH.
>> Laura: WHETHER IT'S THE
SURGEON GENERAL OR THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL, THE HEAD OF DHS, SOME
DIPPY WOMAN AND CHARGE OF THE
INFORMATION BOARD, IT'S SENDING
A CHILLING MESSAGE OF
INTIMIDATION TO CRITICS OF
VARIOUS GOVERNMENT POLICIES.
YOU CAN'T GET AWAY FROM THAT.
THERE WAS A PRETTY SPARSELY
COVERED HOUSE HEARING THAT TOOK
PLACE A COUPLE DAYS AGO.
A PROFESSOR THAT THE BIDEN DHS
IS GIVING OVER LIKE HALF A
MILLION DOLLARS TWO.
HE EXCHANGED IN THIS INTERESTING
CONVERSATION WITH CONGRESSMAN
DAN BISHOP.
WATCH.
>> YOU DESCRIBE IT AS A FORM OF
INCITED TERRORISM WHEREBY A
COMMUNICATOR HAS ACCESS TO A
PLATFORM AND A BIG AUDIENCE.
WITH RESPECT TO THE 2019 EL PASO
SHOULD INCOME A PRESIDENT TRUMP
WAS A SPELL CASTING TERRORIST OF
THAT EVENT RIGHT
>> AMONGST OTHERS, YES.
IT RELATES TO COLLECTING DATA IF
ONE CONNECTS TO THE OTHER.
THAT'S THE RESEARCH I'M TRYING
TO CONDUCT NOW.
>> Laura: GLENN, NOW THE
PROFESSORIATE IS IN ON THE GAME
AS WELL.
>> WHAT THEY ARE DOING IS
PROPAGATING THEORIES THAT HAVE
BEEN LONG USED BY SENSORS TO
JUSTIFY CENSORSHIP OF THE
INTERNET.
LET'S IMAGINE YOU PROBABLY
CALLED THREE YEARS AGO SOMEBODY
WENT TO A SOFTBALL FIELD WHERE
REPUBLICAN CONGRESSMEN
CONGREGATE TO PLAY SOFTBALL AND
SHOT AS MANY AS THEY COULD
ALMOST KILLING STEVE SCALISE.
THEY TURNED OUT HE WAS A VERY
FANATICAL FAN OF THE RACHEL
MADDOW SHOW, FAN OF
BERNIE SANDERS.
WELL, THAT'S INSIGHTFUL
TERRORISM, THEY LEAD PEOPLE TO
DO VIOLENCE.
THE PERSON ARRESTED OUTSIDE
BRETT KAVANAUGH'S HOUSE
ATTEMPTING TO MURDER HIM BECAUSE
HE DIDN'T LIKE THE WAY HE IS
GOING TO VOTE ON GUN CONTROL.
WHO RADICALIZED HIM?
THESE ARE TERRORISTS, THE WORST
AND MOST DANGEROUS THEORIES THAT
HAVE BEEN LONG BEEN DONE BUNKED
AND DISCREDITED.
IT'S DISINFORMATION, HATE
SPEECH, IT'S ALL THE THINGS IN
AN ATTEMPT TO PREVENT US FROM